welcome to my weird and wonderful odd
cabin the police have joined us it's a
party ah don't mind that weird buzzing
noise there is a fish tank above my head
classic euphemism hello I welcome to my
channel if you do not know me my name is
grace Helbig I hope that that changes
your life today I'm doing a stream of
consciousness video where I just talked
to you very stream of consciousness
uh-huh I have one of those moments I
thought my shirt was on backwards but
it's not I guess there are two types of
people people that constantly wonder if
their shirt is on backwards and check
and people that just don't wander and
find out at the end of the day is if
their shirts been backwards the whole
time oh my god also I have a zit right
here and that weird
how did that happen that dirt
accumulated right there I guess cause
like when I eat I'm just shoving food in
my mouth like a pig in a trough and so
the food just couldn't like sometimes
spreads to this area of my mouth so
what's going on in the world and things
in life and stuff how are you guys you
made it to Friday the day after st.
Patrick's Day
normally I shotgun a beer on st.
Patrick's Day but I didn't upload a
video on st. Patrick's Day so I didn't
do it this year I'm sorry you guys am I
getting lazier or am I getting more
mature this is King profoundest [ __ ]
already
oh I don't want to sit all the way back
in this chair look how I'm not stressed
out and casual I look when I sit all the
way back in this chair
who's going to VidCon who loves
answering questions to a person that
actually cannot physically hear their
answers
let's see what's trending on Twitter
maybe that's a great place to start to
relate to you I got a rose gold Mophie
case I'm not a rose gold kind of girl
I'm more of a girl that buys gold
jewelry and then like gets it wet and
doesn't take care of it and so it slowly
fades until you a rose gold flush like
green gold kind of thing what's trending
on Twitter how do I even check Twitter
trends on my phone I go to moments the
airball heard round the world oh no oh
no
oh it's me as an athletic moment what
else has happened today let's go to fun
you know what tab is not fun when it's
labeled fun forget that Keano meet
lonely George Lucas George Lucas eating
a meal by himself looking kind of sad
but here's my question who is actually
sad in this photo is that George Lucas
or is it the person taking the photo of
George Lucas the jury's out they're all
gay there are so many options for a
Trump University mascot
I can't even click on that because you
guys the Trump thing is Shane stupid
louis c.k wrote this very wonderful
letter it's linked in my description and
i beg you to read it money doesn't buy
you compassion money doesn't buy you
rationale i'm breaking out in hives
because it makes me so sad and so
anxious let's break everything up with
the song that was my cover tooth
harmonies work work work work work
Donald Trump isn't the only one that can
convince themselves of an alternate
reality than what is actually happening
ah compelling argument huh wherever's am
ia been east m-i-a m-i-a oh let's see
what else is happening on the internet
I've watched people be racist and sexist
but I don't think I've watched anything
as awful as that snapchat filter that
turns your eyeballs into your mouth I
hate it
two things I want to go dancing and I
want to go to an amusement park and ride
a roller coaster and just really feel
how old my actual body is I have been
smelling rogue farts when I am alone so
much do ghosts fart and if so I have so
many ghosts in my house and all of them
have gas I've been getting so many zits
in my eyebrows lately riddle me that
someone tell me how to fix it though
seriously and I have a zit up here like
my face is creating its own Braille that
says please wash me more ah I just
looked at
the news tab of the Twitter mentions oh
it's a whole lot of everything bad Wow
chocolate chocolates great right that's
a great I've been sitting here for 23
minutes filming myself doing nothing
absolutely nothing I hope this was
enjoyable for you dish is out have you
downloaded the app if you like checking
photos of your food I think you would
like it 3030 soon dr. Medina grill soon
a couple of the projects you don't know
about yet but soon soon has got to stop
I'm sorry I'd be like sure I'm
consciousness videos let me know in the
comments down below and by liking this
video because I like doing these so I
would love to do these more often if
it's something you're into also please
subscribe if you haven't already because
I would love to hit three million
subscribers before VidCon they're done
I'm making it an actual thing so please
subscribe if you haven't already my
friends would love you too alright we're
done here
I don't know what are you guys into you
recently said you're not narc internet
friend